In previous decades, most media with global reach...
...consisted of several major newspapers and networks...
...which had the resources to gather information directly.
Outlets like Reuters and the Associated Press...
...that aggregate or re-report stories...
...were relatively rare compared to today.
The speed with which information spreads now...
...has created the ideal conditions...
...for a phenomenon known as circular reporting.
This is when publication A publishes misinformation,...
...publication B reprints it,...
...and publication A then cites B as the source for the information.
It's also considered a form of circular reporting when multiple publications...
...report on the same initial piece of false information,...
...which then appears to another author...
...as having been verified by multiple sources.
For instance, the 1998 publication of a single pseudoscientific paper...
...arguing that routine vaccination of children causes autism...
...inspired an entire anti-vaccination movement,...
...despite the fact that the original paper...
...has repeatedly been discredited by the scientific community.
Deliberately unvaccinated children are now contracting contagious diseases...
...that had been virtually eradicated in the United States,...
...with some infections proving fatal.